United Kingdom it's having an election
in May both parties are campaigning hard
especially for women voters the
Conservative Party has been accused of
ignoring women in the past so the Labour
Party may have a chance to capitalize as
long as they don't make any ridiculous
mistakes the Labour Party has been
defending the color it's chosen for a
minibus which is being used in a
campaign to try to attract female voters
the Deputy Labour leader Harriet Harman
has defended the decision to use the
colour on the vehicle already nicknamed
the Barbie bus wow it is a little
insulting that you're trying to appeal
to adults women voters the same way that
Mattel attempts to appeal to
eight-year-olds and at least Barbies
pink bus had the good sense to unfold
into a sweet hot tub and party Den combo
that thing was sick understandably this
bus has been more than a little
controversial with many women in Britain
reacting like this we're politically
minded we can read and we can access
information in the way that men or
anyone else can I think the pink bus is
a bit patronizing a bit patronizing the
only way it can be more patronizing is
if it's wheels were giant nuva rings and
they refuse to let women drive it that
for some reason instead of apologizing
the Labour Party has tried to deny what
color the van is insisting it was cerise
or magenta or trying to avoid the
question altogether and just so we've
got it on the record what color is this
hots uh I'll tell you where we got look
I mean it's like pink sarees but I mean
I don't know people will call this this
colour it's certainly a version of pink
I would say I think she may have just
hit rock bottom you can see our thinking
I've gone into politics to make a
difference and now I'm on television
desperately trying to act like I don't
know the color pink what happened to my
life
if this wasn't bad enough the Labour
Party claimed this is all part of an
effort to reach out to women and have a
conversation about the kitchen table and
around the kitchen table rather than
having an economy that just reaches the
boardroom table yeah you know women they
want to talk to you where you are not in
a boardroom but in a kitchen or in a
baby gap underneath a giant pile of yarn
and romance novels you know the places
you go incredibly the pink bus has still
not being discontinued and at this point
I'm almost glad that labor is not doing
damage control because I'm afraid that
if they did it would look like this
women of the United Kingdom the Labour
Party would like to apologise to you for
our wrongheaded pink van campaign we
want you to know that labour respects
you which is why this general election
we will focus on the issues that we no
matter to you and that means ponies look
at the pretty pony it's a very pretty
pony isn't it women like you labour
cares about this pony we'll brush it's
pretty pony hair and before you get
offended you're right a pony is not
enough that's why we dressed the pony up
in the pretty princess outfit princess
princess pony princess pony vote for
labour in May and if you're very good we
will come to your kitchen and you can
perm the pretty princess pony oh don't
be scared
she's a nice pony not a mean party good
better pony do it now bet the pretty
princess boating labor cares about
women's issues all of them so when it's
time to vote remember you love ponies
labour has a pony pony pony pony
Odie's for labor
you